es könnte sein dass diese bilder schon
das ende all seiner kanzler träume waren
[Musik]
dem kanzlerkandidaten der union wird
gleich zu beginn des wahlkampfes die
wichtigste eigenschaft eines kanzlers
quasi weggespült das vertrauen in seine
führungsfähigkeit
mangelndes management schlechte
kommunikation und noch schlechtere
umfragen nach schätzt kampagne ist im
sturzflug den vergleich mit der
konkurrenz verliert er inzwischen
krachend
dabei ist eine krise auch um eine chance
für anpacker für macher für einen
landesvater doch armin laschet zerstört
all das als er völlig unpassend über
witze lacht während der bundespräsident
über tod und leid redet da helfen auch
alle entschuldigungen nichts es war blöd
und es sollte nicht sein und ich bin da
auch
armin laschet ist ein getriebener
kandidat getrieben vor allem von ihm
markus söder hat bis heute offenbar
nicht verwunden den kürzeren gezogen zu
haben und der piesackt den chef der
großen schwesterpartei wo er kann im
machtkampf um die kanzlerkandidatur
lernt söder und mit ihm die ganze
republik das auch laschet eine harte ja
hartnäckige seite hat dass er nicht
einfach zurückzieht auch wenn ihm der
wind direkt ins gesicht weht aminat in
einem der interviews letzten gezeigt und
ist fand ich wichtig und auch
beeindruckend es soll dann am ende
derjenige der kanzlerkandidat sein der
die besten wahlchancen für unser für
unsere gemeinsame idee hat alles spreche
doch für ihn den bayern und gegen den
frisch gewählten cdu vorsitzenden denkt
söder und muss einsehen wie tief er sich
getäuscht hat seine unverhohlene
aufforderung an laschet verhallt
ungehört auch weil der das nie vorhatte
dass die cdu das lasche die gefühlte
mehrheit in partei fraktion und unter
den wlan ignoriert das hat söder einfach
nicht geglaubt die bereitschaft von
zweien liegt auf dem tisch die
aufgabenstellung liegt auch auf dem
tisch und jetzt werden wir diese
beratungen morgen zunächst in der cdu
und dann in der csu erleben
fast zehn tage lang halten die beiden
spitzen egos ihre parteien im april in
atem und beschädigen so ganz nebenbei
den künftigen kanzlerkandidaten
dass laschet nicht zugunsten söders
verzichtet für die cdu spitze eine
prinzipienfrage und die erfahrung dass
schon die kandidaturen von straußen
stoiber erfolglos waren
am ende muss das csu klein beigeben
allerdings nicht ohne schon am tag des
verzichts nachzutreten
ich bedanke mich da ausdrücklich dafür
bei vielen vielen orts und
kreisverbänden der cdu besonders ich
bedanke mich sehr bei
arbeitsgemeinschaft gerade bei den
jungen bei den modernen bei denen die
auf zukunft auswahl für ihre wirklich
überragende unterstützung
ich bedanke mich vor allem auch bei
vielen mutigen abgeordneten die entgegen
normale partei solidarität sehr offen
gesagt haben was sie schätzen ich
bedanke mich auch bei nahezu allen
ministerpräsidenten die gerade den
letzten tagen auch noch mal
unterstützung gezeigt haben und ganz
besonders bei unglaublich vielen bürgern
und bürgern unseres landes nicht nur aus
bayern markus söder war erkennbar der
kandidat der herzen
laschet weiß um die großen schuhe die er
anstrebt für ihn nie ein lebenstraum
sondern die einsicht dass
cdu-vorsitzende auch immer nach dem
chefsessel im kanzleramt streben müssen
als ich in die cdu in meiner jugend
eingetreten bin habe ich das nie
mit der vorstellung gemacht einmal
bundeskanzler zu werden ein
eingeständnis dass tief in laschet seele
blicken lässt und vielleicht manches
klarer macht
doch den machtwillen des aacheners zu
unterschätzen haben schon andere gebüßt
im einjährigen kampf um den cdu vorsitz
setzt sich laschet gegen norbert röttgen
und friedrich merz durch
insbesondere märz war sich zeitweise
sicher der sieger der herzen zu sein ein
fataler irrtum sein vorwurf gegen die
parteispitze läuft ins leere wendet sich
sogar gegen das ich nicht der liebling
des partei establishments in berlin bild
das wissen sie auch
laschet hält sich damals zurück so wie
es oft seine art ist
abwarten und die eigenen stärken betonen
ist sein motto
man muss als erstes gerade in dieser
corona pandemie die gesellschaft
zusammenhalten viele sagen das müsste
man machen ich sag das mache ich
laschet der damals im duo mit jens spahn
antritt betont in seiner kandidatur
immer seine regierungserfahrung seine
rolle als ministerpräsident des größten
bundesland
so will er auch all jenen den wind aus
den segeln nehmen jena als zauderer und
wankelmütig beschreiben
ist das korrekt beschrieben nein
sie haben den willen zur macht er wie
sie werden nicht ministerpräsident von
nordrhein westfalen
50 jahre eine andere partei regiert hat
wenn sie nicht die idee haben was sie
aus dem land machen wollen und wenn sie
am ende nicht auch gewinnen wollen und
so haben wir den wahlkampf 217 angelegt
und so muss man jeden wahlkampagne
laschet gilt als teamspieler nicht er
ist der star sondern sein team immer
wieder betont er die unterschiedlichen
charaktere in seinem düsseldorfer
kabinett und diese teammitglieder danken
es ihm mit großer loyalität
ich warne davor auf umfragen zu gucken
also wenn man politik danach ausrichtet
war es gerade stimmung des tages ist da
kannst dich medien lassen die leute
spüren dass die leute wollen eine echte
politiker
auf dem parteitag zahlt sich das aus
langjährige kontaktpflege das
versprechen den kompass der partei nicht
zu verschieben bringt am ende die
mehrheit knapp aber doch klar laschet
wird der neue cdu vorsitzende
und der mann der sonst eher ein
mittelmäßiger redner ist greift tief in
die rhetorische trickkiste
es geht um die für die demokratie
wichtigste frage
wem vertrauen
das entscheiden heute
sie
es ist laschet unbekümmertheit die die
beobachter immer wieder erstaunt jetzt
wochen vor der wahl das vertrauen das er
beschwört scheint längst aufgebraucht
war kämpft armin laschet sich durch die
republik die partei ist längst
hochnervös laschet tut so als ob ihn das
alles nichts ausmacht
es hat neumeier jut jejange das
rheinische motto leitet ihn manchmal
vielleicht zu oft
2017 im kampf mit hannelore kraft lag er
auch scheinbar verloren zurück um am
ende triumphieren
ist das jetzt wieder seine hoffnung
armin laschet hat er eine gewisse
sorglosigkeit würde ich sagen in der
vorbereitung das was nach außen hin dann
immer so ein bisschen chaotisch anmutet
insofern kann man durchaus sagen sein
größter gegner an mancher stelle ist er
selbst
und so stolpert laschet und mit ihm die
gesamte deutsche politik in die nächste
krise aus kabul erreichen den kandidaten
dramatische bilder armin laschet für den
aus- und politik immer ein steckenpferd
war eigentlich die chance stärke zu
zeigen
die plötzliche machtübernahme der
taliban in afghanistan
die verkorkste rettungsmission der
internationalen gemeinschaft zwingt den
kandidaten dazu position zu beziehen und
er versucht sich abzugrenzen von der
eigenen regierung und von einem einsatz
den er lange unterstützt hat
[Musik]
dass dieses engagement der
internationalen gemeinschaft nicht
erfolgreich war es ist das größte
debakel das die nato seit ihrer gründung
erleidet
und er der immer für eine offene
flüchtlingspolitik stand und wohl auch
noch steht bedient mit einem satz den
rechten rand seiner partei
plötzlich wird aus einer diplomatischen
militärischen und vor allem humanitären
katastrophe ein wahlkampfthema
wir dürfen die fehler von 2015 nicht
wiederholen
eine unglückliche formulierung hier eine
missverständliche geste da haben ihn
laschet kämpft mit und um sein image
sein oft abwägender charakter der schon
immer auf konsens gepolt ist hilft ihm
gerade nicht vielleicht da schon eher
dass auch aufgeben nicht so seine sache
ist
armin laschet würde wahrscheinlich sagen
es hätt noch immer jot jejange